what are his powers what's up with the
bad guy do superheroes have a group chat
or what
riding on the high of the mischievous
hilarious and sometimes touching film we
want to clear up a couple questions
about billy batson and his bigger better
self
shazam opens with the creation of the
villain thaddeus savannah
bullied and belittled by his family he
is naturally tempted by the voices of
the seven deadly sins who promise power
and respect
he fails the wizard's test and is
forever scarred the wizard casts a spell
to seek the pure apart and find someone
worthy of his name when billy batson
takes the test
things go differently billy batson
i choose you the sins aren't there to
tempt him and the wizard chooses him as
champion savannah's research indicates
that hundreds of people have been found
before billy
and each had in some way failed were
they all sinners at their core
why was the wizard so picky in the first
place the wizard had been burned before
bequeathing his power to death adam who
became a tyrant
and unleashed the seven deadly sins
originally black adam as portrayed by
dwayne the rock johnson himself was set
to appear in the film
perhaps we'll see exactly what happens
when a wizard gives power to someone not
so pure of heart
in the black adam solo film there are
really hard and fast rules for magic
which makes this implementation
confusing in shazam
savannah billy and countless other
people are spirited away
to a cave-like lair known as the rock of
eternity there the wizard resides
surrounded by empty thrones the seven
deadly sins are imprisoned in stone
this place isn't on any map much to the
frustration of savannah who dedicates
his life to finding it
it's in kind of a limbo that can only be
accessed through magic according to the
comics the rock of eternity resides
within multiple dimensions at once
this helps explain a thoroughly
confusing sequence during which billy
and his new family
run around the maze-like rock and
discover a collection of doors
straight out of monsters inc behind each
one there's some kind of strange of the
world
the movie's explanation of this is
basically just because magic
people typically don't fund mad
scientists they are forced to work in
abandoned castles and basement labs
their only friend a typically inept and
malformed crony but not dr savannah he
has a couple dozen scientists working
under him in a busy lab
only when you walk into his personal
office does his lifetime obsession with
the mythical rock of eternity
and seven deadly sins begin to show
savannah has been especially smart to
hide his desperate search into the realm
of unknowable magic
as a study of mass hallucination
savannah industries seems to be a
lucrative business
on par with wayne enterprises and lexcob
it is also a family company as
emphasized from the patronizing video
that plays in the building's elevator
maybe savannah industries had involved
with mental health or behavioral studies
in the dc extended universe which would
have allowed savannah to inconspicuously
study magic under his alibi
plus if there have really been so many
wizard abductions that seems like a
worthy phenomena to look into
the seven deadly sins are evil powerful
and seriously ugly the rest of the
details are fuzzy
are they demons the actual seven deadly
sins according to the film
they are manifestations of the worst of
mankind in the comics they were known as
the seven deadly enemies of man which
de-emphasizes
the judeo-christian connection the
comics also explain exactly how they
carry out their chaotic plans
which seems to involve causing as much
misery as possible
envy greed wrath gluttony lust sloth and
pride speak sweet nothings to their
victims promising that they'll give them
whatever their hearts desire they do
give full power but at a cost
their sins possess their victims so
savannah's own evil tendencies were
amplified
demon might not be the most correct
terminology but they sure looked the
part
in the world of shazam just about
anything seems possible
superheroes can be spotted flying there
are secret kingdoms beneath the waves
superman sometimes shows up in high
school cafeterias and according to the
law
artfully detailed in wonder woman the
greek pantheon was very real and very
powerful
they were killed by ares except for zeus
who created the amazonians to protect
humanity from the god of war's wrath
shazam's powers are derived from and
equivalent to some of the most famous
names in mythology
which suggests that perhaps they
themselves have been involved with the
wizards on the rock of eternity
when billy grasps the staff of the
wizard which yes i'm
phrasing is that still a thing he is
gifted with the wisdom of solomon and
the strength of hercules the stamina of
atlas
the power of zeus the courage of
achilles and the speed of mercury
who goes by his roman name the first
letters of their names spell out shazam
wait for real say okay shazam
billy doesn't seem to be too wise when
it comes to handling his powers
responsibly
but his lightning hands are certainly
zeus-like the first scenes of the film
of sins lined up conveniently in the
rock of eternity
they're just as terrible in stone as
they are in flesh when savannah absorbs
them
and takes him into the mortal plane when
he confronts the board of his father's
company
the sleek conference room quickly crowds
when seven demonic entities crash the
meeting
even though they exist in smoke and dust
in savannah's evil eye they are
solid when they unceremoniously rip into
the board members lust has tentacles
greed an extra set of arms gluttony a
huge mouth with big teeth
envy a goblin-like appearance sloth has
sloth arms and the pride has huge bat
wings and horns
the comics mention that pride might be
the most dangerous of all the seven
deadly sins but the winged nightmare
seems content to give center stage to
its buddies
it isn't a surprise when freddy's
youtube video of captain sparkle fingers
or the red cyclone go viral
in the dc eu youtube must be filled with
quick moments of superheroes caught on
tape what's surprising is that people in
the movie aren't all that enthralled
with a new hero whose powers seem to
rival those of superman's
remember that this is in the same
universe where superman was compared to
a god
shazam only manages to gather a small
crowd of admirers when he's showing off
his lightning hands
the tone of shazam marks a notable
departure from the very serious dark and
gritty films of the dc eu instead of
digging into the international uproar
from the appearance of another
superhuman
the movie focuses on the kids than the
cast director david f sandberg has said
that he mind the spielberg directed
adventures of his childhood
and the expertise of the kids on set for
a more fun tone
shazam is a family film so there are
fortnight references instead of bloody
death scenes
shazam is one of very few superhero
characters that is
genuinely stoked to be a superhero is
shazam overpowered the twist that saved
everyone's bacon when things looked
darkest was that billy as champion
could share his power with his family
with the shouts of shazam and a burst of
lightning
all the kids get a superhero makeover
all adult
athletic and ultra powerful they each
seem to have a particularly strong dose
of one of shazam's signature powers
whether that's speed vidala
flight for freddy or strength for pedro
though it seems all of shazam's powers
have been split among the kids
billy still at his full arsenal this
suggests that billy could have made a
whole army of superheroes before he
snapped the wizard's magical staff in
half
this may have been part of the wizard's
grand scheme considering the md thrones
on the rock of eternity
it would be up to the new champion to
fill them and billy expedites the
process by creating five new shazams
the kids in the vazquez house are pretty
smart eugene for example is our next
level computer whereas who manages to
track down billy's birth mother
they think fast and are incredibly
perceptive they adjust relatively well
to being introduced to a world of super
villains and smoke monsters they seem to
instantly recognize the ugly monsters in
savannah's eye
as sins mary realizes they are somehow
connected to how strong savannah is if
we missed the part where they were given
an explanation
they've proven time and again to be
quick studies freddie is a superhero
expert
you're the only person i know that knows
anything about this cape crusader stuff
mary did everything she could to get
into her dream college even quiet pedro
was the one to find billy's book full of
leads on the location of his mom
as it turns out envy is actually one of
the more dangerous sins
it stays cozied up in savannah's evil
life for as long as possible
until billy manages to finally provoke
it out of hiding why envy
the sins work by preying on base
instincts and feelings
envy's the most powerful feeling for
savannah because he envies billy for
having been chosen as shazam's champion
envious and bitter he makes himself into
the sims champion despite the wizard who
said he wasn't good enough
envy eats him up inside and without it
he was powerless
the end credit scenes after superhero
movies are often clues for what's to
come
usually only the most ardent of comic
fans know exactly what's happening in
these brief snatches of exposition
in the mid-credit scene from shazam when
savannah is seen madly scribbling
graffiti on his prison cell we start to
understand the importance of that little
caterpillar seen at the rock of eternity
his name is mr mind and is one of the
most diabolical creatures in the dc
universe
as his name suggests he's super smart
and he uses his incredible intellect for
evil
in the comics this little worm had the
plan to assemble the monster society of
evil
savannah is likely the first recruit
having teamed up with mr mind in the
comics many times before
mr mind also has mind control powers
which probably come in handy when trying
to take over the world we've yet to see
exactly what his plans are in the dc eu
but they are not good it's easy to
assume that most superheroes know
each other or are at least aware of each
other powerful figures like superman or
personalities like aquamans are hard to
miss
justice league allowed them to really
get to know each other for billy these
are still legendary figures akin to
celebrities
he's probably just as excited as freddy
to meet superman for the first time
in the comics supes and billy go way
back black adam the aforementioned
champion gone bad
is powerful enough to make even the
almighty superman bulk
it takes the combined might of shazam
and superman to take him down in the
2010 animated movie superman
shazam the return of black adam with a
black adam film on the way
presumably with a slightly grittier feel
than shazam the superman cameo might be
connected with black adam's return
maybe superman needed information from
shazam about a similarly powered villain
on the rise
or maybe he's something of a welcoming
committee for new superheroes
at least he would have felt the need to
check out a new ultra powerful hero
just to make sure he doesn't have any
villainous tendencies
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
shazam are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you